bah-bah hmm hello and welcome to new
world review your source for everything
anime I guess I never checked with Liam
what I'm actually supposed to say here
so I guess I'll just keep doing what I'm
doing until he corrects me hi it's me
again
brand line waifu here for episode 2 and
3 of Hunter hunter I'm sorry that was
awful I just so after the last episode I
wasn't exactly sure how to come at this
review I was so desperate to tap the
play next episode button because while
I'm not a Binger I felt like the chapter
of the story wasn't finished so it took
great fortitude on my part to hit pause
to discuss it I guess I'm a famine
almost sort of let's just say that so
far I'm enjoying the story I'm sure
you've all seen it before but just as a
heads-up because I know some people may
not have and I don't like spoiling
things for people I'm throwing caution
to the winds and yelling out spoiler on
this which admittedly I should have done
before but it really didn't occur to me
to do so and I wasn't sure I would keep
going with this but it looks as though
for now at least I am so I'm beware the
spoil monster and let's go
so episode 2 I had mixed feelings about
this episode on the one hand I really
enjoyed the ongoing importance placed on
emotion and decisions on the other gone
is beginning to give me serious
creepster vibes an interesting choice
for a 12 year old I'll explain what I
mean I got my first indication in this
episode that Gaughan is abnormal an old
woman asked them whether they would
sacrifice their daughter or son in a
life-and-death situation and gone sits
to contemplate the answer yes sure he
has an unbreakable fishing rod and he's
absurdly strong for a 12 year old and he
has hair that he never touches that
seems to maintain very consistent peaks
and he's constantly light-hearted in a
way that makes literally no sense but
the thing that strikes me is that Gahan
is having sacrificial thoughts at all
the old woman notices too they all
notice at first I was amused he was
still considering the question because I
thought it was further indication of his
buffoonery hearing why though it made me
see him as someone others should
probably be worried about and the sound
in this moment followed us taking a
minor turn and heightening the
importance of the question because his
light-hearted or his character is the
other main characters dismiss a
philosophical question because of their
capacity for empathy Gahan seems able to
step away from empathy and into measured
judgment that's important and it speaks
to the ease with which he left me to--in
episode
one despite her obvious concerns he
didn't try to make her feel better about
him leaving which could be dismissed as
just an excitable twelve-year-old
response now I think about all the times
gone has interacted with people in what
at the time I thought were empathetic
ways and I realized they were just
observations
he's an observant kid and he's a
cutthroat kid and we can't ignore that
it makes him creepy whatever his father
is whatever hunters are they're not
normal and that's kind of what lee oreo
is for all his lanky briefcase carrying
hoity-toity bravado he's the moral
compass for now and I really appreciate
having that moral compass be so
obviously designed to be basically the
opposite of gone where gone is silently
calculating an outcome that should be
emotionally fraught the Oreo is throwing
us through the emotional wringer joining
us in how we feel but in his own comic
way and I mean yes it's comic but it's
also earnest and as much as I felt he
was overdoing it he's an animation and
that's exactly what he should do
everything about lis Oreo is endearing
because despite his desire to be
recognized and famous he seems to have
the greatest capacity for empathy and
vulnerability and I respect that which
is quite the shift for me from episode 1
to 2 it seems we don't take long to
begin to detail these on the surface
simple characters korabik I might be the
one I understand the least because he
seems to be the least complicated he
thinks carefully he's deliberate and
stable even looking back to his anger in
the first episode he was the measured
calm oppositely Oreo and he has yet to
have a moment of rashness which I'm
going to want to see that longer he
stays calm
he gets mad at the kid he called Leigh
Oreo copycat but it's controlled anger
he gets Stern with the caracal woman but
not angry I want to see rage give me
that rage and I suppose that's the crux
of the matter for me so far we have one
main character carrying the team in
terms of actual shifting emotions Leigh
Oreo I'm not sure about everyone else
who watches but that's not something I'm
going to be okay with long-term I expect
character shift I expect emotional
strife or at least that's what I look
for and what I hope for when I watch
something I want the characters to be
changed by what they experience because
I'm changed by seeing them experience
I know it's still very early on and
we're just introducing the characters of
the world but still speaking of the
world it's clearly very close to ours
but
broken the Cybermen are here for example
I was very confused and disconcerted by
the band that started out being a band
but only actually consisted of two
instruments a raven that caught on
command and a horn that tooted I'm not
sure we needed the rest of them I'm not
sure we needed a lot of what was in that
scene they were great dressing I guess
but the majority of that was entirely
irrelevant unless it comes back in which
case you'll hear me make a delicious
dinner of my words what I've noticed as
of episode 2 is that we don't actually
have any evil characters there's no
actual people with good or bad
intentions and everyone in the world so
far seems to dedicate their entire lives
to this hunter test which I didn't care
about after episode 1 but it seems to be
all anyone thinks about in episode 2
what I would love to be the case not
having seen episode 3 at the point of
writing the first half of this review is
for the whole thing to have been a hoax
and for their not to actually be a test
at the end of episode 2 a point is made
that they're being flown to the starting
line that's what they were told at the
end of episode 1 to 1 also I wonder how
long they can draw out this concept what
I'm missing though even at this early
point is a feeling of tension the story
is very much there I'm understanding the
characters I don't understand the hunter
exam at all and I'm happy to go along
with it still but it's all quite mild
which is odd given everyone keep saying
it's going to be intensely dark so this
is me saying hey I'm ready
give me the dark stuff mess me up maybe
episode 3 will take us to that dark
place because I'm so ready 20 minutes
later let's talk about episode 3 finally
knowing about our intrepid main cast we
turned our attention to all the other
weird people taking the test or at least
the ones who will probably become for
plot reasons important we made our first
objectively evil character here and
again I'm glad there is a show don't
tell rule in place seeing him dissolve
in man's arms and flowers was so much
more satisfying ly beautiful than I
thought it could be even though I knew
it was unfortunate for the guy who lost
his arm
I guess rules are important don't
shoulder check and you keep your arms it
also made clear the hunter test is
unbound by morality which is a huge
counterpoint to the previous episodes
that seemed to focus very heavily on the
morality of the characters we followed
so far and it tells me something about
the hunter test which is fantastic
finally something one way to look at
this is to make
clear our standpoint the morality that
is where the good people on the side of
the good people another way to look at
this is to accept and acknowledge how
complex our main characters are compared
to the characters we're being introduced
to now are they going to lean into that
darkness and become the silhouettes we
see in the opening vignette will the
other character step out of the
stereotypes we were given will opening
credits guy Q WA turn out to be more
than a skateboarding dude brah who
suspiciously tolerant of poisons well
our secret not secret ninja turn out to
have more than secret not secret ninja
powers as a suspicion here I think he's
actually two people but we'll see Oh
we'll smarmy smart kid remains mommy
will he wash his hair I have no idea I
hope so but how does he run with a
laptop open I've tried that maybe his
true skill in Tonpa poor outmatched
Tonpa what are we to do with him he
seems to be a good measure of failure
the longer he lost the worst we can see
everyone else is doing after all he's
been doing this test for 30 odd years
and he still seems to be surprised by
the newbies and still seems to be using
the same trick he's used for years based
on how others treat him we'll time to
learn probably not mechanically gone is
beginning to look like a Mary Sue he
seems to naturally have accounts to
every issue seems to know a way out of
every problem and seems content to just
let things happen I am instantly
suspicious of this simply because of the
previous two episodes but if it turns
out that he is in fact an entirely
uncomplicated 12 year old I will be very
unhappy talking with such guy takes the
award for being the most entertaining
person in this episode my only wish was
that he on turning had said walk this
way I wish this because I am a pun
loving kind of gal and I possibly I
alone would have appreciated it instead
I was left wanting
as his perfectly curled mustache and
head horn did all the talking while he
did all the walking karappa Carr
continues to be our thinker our deep
thinker with a serious understanding of
the psychological issues involved in
every test so far the audio continues to
be unsure of everything around him will
that change the longer they're in each
other's space I doubt it mostly because
they have their own stereotypes to stick
to but I'm willing to be surprised that
said this episode was less about r3 and
more about the vibe of the test and
those taking it magic has finally been
introduced magic and strange forces
having left their home it's great to see
the world beginning
to open up in the eyes of the characters
and it's a great setting to have them
brought underground to further highlight
that the focus of the episode is on the
characters and their personalities
rather than the broader environment it
would be an interesting exercise to sort
each group taking the test in two
locations I wonder whether there are
similarities in their personalities
versus where they're from but again
that's my inner psychologist talking as
you were the tension in the room didn't
feel particularly present again and I
still get the feeling they know as much
as I do about the actual test which
makes sense since it keeps changing
apparently something I think I'm
struggling with still is that lack of
tension around the test in general as
such a character focus show I should be
more invested in how important this test
is to them they're all sort of walking
through things quite easily I get the
feeling I could be given more be it
verbally visually or through sound
design than I'm getting right now we
keep hearing about money and honor but
it doesn't seem from this episode that
either the audio or karateka will be
satisfied by the hunters they actually
meet in the real world and without any
actual hunters to compare it to I can't
begin to judge whether they would
actually enjoy being hunters themselves
occasional arguments about the
importance of being a hunter is
wonderful but it does nothing to make
the actual test or why anyone would take
it clearer for me even now that we've
started phase one and one more thing
where are the women girls females anyone
not masculine I'm sure people may have
problems with me bringing this up but it
still bears mentioning the only women
involved so far that I've seen have been
in the helping roles I am so ready to
see some kickass women with some super
abilities I'm ready for complexity in
those women rather than just boobs
because boobs are great but they're not
so good at holding conversation trust me
I've tried I have hopes because I
noticed that Mito wasn't just talking
boobs but I also have extreme doubts
about whether this anime will give me
anything approaching strength in femme
characters or regularity in themed
characters though I'll be honest and say
I very much thought and hoped karapa car
was femme in the first episode for all
of about two minutes we'll see how
things progress and I'll probably come
back to that question since I'm a lady
girl myself
for now though that's all from me if you
enjoyed this video in the content this
channel produces in general please do
consider donating to the New World
review
Treon because the support of all of you
amazing people is what continues to make
this channel possible if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun then please
do head over to the discord server where
a wide array of shenanigan ori takes
place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your thoughts on
tests of tests and rivals for survival
episodes 2 & 3 of Hunter hunter this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]